hello everyone how are you guys doing
hope you guys are having a wonderful day
today is episode one of noob with a male
that's just gonna be what the series is
called
I don't know couldn't come up with
anything too creative so I feel like
it's pretty self-explanatory though you
know it gets across the point of the
series in the title which I like so
basically I have that noob account my
merch account that you guys saw that
I've made like from 5 mil I brought it
up to like 150 ish and that was pretty
sick right so how about I do that on an
account where you know same stats but
now I have access to everything I'm
going to level the account I'm going to
merge I'm going to flip I'm going to
just do insane money making methods I
did one this video so you guys see that
in the future but yeah I'll just be
doing stuff like that this series so I
hope you guys are excited for it and
that further ado let's get into episode
1 and there we go completed Romeo and
Juliet questions I mean I don't know I'm
just gonna go insert question for a
little bit I think is the best way to
start this up alright so I'm gonna go do
druidic rituals and yeah I don't know
just a pretty simple simple quest that
I'm hoping to get knocked out of the way
real quick literally one of the easiest
quest I did not know that it was that
quick but that's an easy for quest point
so we got out of the way so I kind of
found a list of the most efficient
quests to do on reddit so I'm gonna kind
of go by that and then see how far I can
get before I get bored alright so I just
got done that quest and want to go do
dwarf Canon but almost all of our birds
nuts have bought so I'm gonna wait for
these final five to buy and just kind of
test the TV per hour that I can get off
of just crushing these which is actually
surprisingly good alright so as you can
see right here we have a hundred eighty
eight birds nuts and I bought those for
a total of 760 kay that took two minutes
and 40 seconds but here we go 180
crushed bird's nest
as you can see 814 K is the guide price
I'm gonna see what I bought these for so
that was 760 I'm gonna see what I could
actually sell these on for if I were to
buy one and then we'll uh we'll see how
much money we made
alright so 4412 so I'm gonna see what I
could sell all these on for that alright
so medium price we're gonna lower it by
one it's really 830 K is what we ended
up with so 830 K minus the original 760
we were able to make
what is a 70k in a matter of two and a
half minutes and by the way if anyone
says those nests aren't gonna sell I
call [__] because I just started
this cannon quest and they've already
sold so yeah and there we are another
quest done got the dwarf cannon question
cannons could be used in the future I
don't know what level I need for him but
we could definitely find some use for
this all right so now time to go put
this rope to good use
well in that quest I turned the rope
into a week I really don't know what
else I expected but uh
another three quest points there we go
in boom there we go another five quest
points we were knocking these out but I
know these quests are really easy and I
don't want to get too excited because
I'm not really minding it right now
which is different for me
I accidentally dug twice but I guarantee
you I just finished pirate's treasure
where the [__] is oh let me find it Oh
fine let's do this That moment when you
buy all the beads for em catcher to go
do it and you forget that you've already
done it on this account rip all the
sheep here we go let's do you got to do
for the five quest right oh yeah okay
you said something bout a burial okay
gotcha yeah yeah I'm on it I'm on it
don't worry don't worry about me and
here we go five quest points incoming
right now
let's go never mind it was four I did
not know that onto the next one and
there we go after sheep herder decided
to go and do the rest of my bird's nest
so we're gonna go ahead and crush 210 of
these and see how much money we can make
all right so apparently bird's nests
aren't even buying for 5% over which
would mean that I turn I also sold one
on to see what the price was so you can
add another 4k to this so that means I
turned 846 K into 976 not too bad and
this should be the end of another quest
so here we go let's start Edmund and
boom now I can teleport Artie that's
pretty nice that'll be definitely
helpful going forward
also got some mining levels not too
shabby and boom another question you
might be able hear the vacuum in the
background but that'll be done but uh
yeah there we go thirty-eight quest
points a little bit of thieving XP I
don't know if that got me any level but
uh it's like I think I chose the villain
role in his quest which is you know a
little disappointing and I'm not totally
proud of myself but we did just gain
another thieving level and got another
quest point plus two thousand coins like
profit surprisingly enough all right
play that back one more time did I just
say is surprisingly surprisingly oh yeah
I did okay the crushed Nets actually
sold for that much I didn't really
anticipate that so I'm pretty happy with
that I'm gonna go ahead and buy some
more right now I think I need to kind of
stock up on a few more stamina potions
those for these quests the bird's nest
may have gone down oh maybe not I don't
know if they're actively traded price is
pretty low right now so that's not
that's not what I wanted to see and
there we go another 60 to 70 came made
in a short amount of time I'm gonna go
sell off these crunch birds nest and get
back to questions so there we go we have
over a million crushed bird's nest which
means we a 50k plus what we're wearing
which is like I don't know 30k plus I
mean we've been like 200k off of that
and paid first day more potions which is
good alright so about to do the murder
mystery quests but I ended up flipping
some things so as you can see the salt
the thing I don't know how I would say
it but I bought them for 214 K and I was
able to sell them off for 288 so that's
a good profit at least for how much I
invested into it and birds nest right
now I just bought for 4.3 K apparently
from when I found a little bit ago I
would be able to sell them on for 4.9
but I don't know if I'm gonna be able to
get that but we'll see alright so I
bought the bird's nest in total for 810
K and apparently I can sell them on
right now four four nine eight oh if I
subtract one which is how many I bought
that would mean I made about a hundred
and twenty five K which is pretty good
so uh yeah we'll rock that up a little
bit and go do some quest and there we go
murder mystery quest done three more
quest points 2k coins again I don't know
why you even get coin rewards but I'll
take you and did we even get a crafting
level no there's no way I'm 53 but yeah
there's er there is a that quest done
alright so more Birds massive but these
ones bought for 4.2 K so if I'm able to
actually you know crush these and sell
them off that'll be a lot of profit but
right now I think I'm gonna go get some
fire making upike I don't want to do
winter Tod at some point so I'm gonna go
burn off some what willow logs I think I
can do right now is I would
yeah so we'll go do that and there we go
that is 40 fire-making so technically
level wise we were halfway but another
ten levels left and then I got to go
find the clue hunter here I don't know
if that's what it's called but I have to
go find something that will keep me warm
while I do wintertime all right so here
we go just finished off that inventory
and let's do one more log because I
think that's all we're gonna need I'm
gonna grab two just in case so there we
go one more log that should do the trick
right now come on I can't let a fire in
here cut damn it okay well give me a
second there we go 50 fire making going
to go find the clue hunter I've gotta
[__] hate myself for not looking it up
but I'm gonna go find that stuff and
we're gonna get to this actually birds
nests so I was actually able to sell off
all the birds nests so we're up to 1.25
5k just by merging our little bird's
nest here so I'm gonna go ahead and go
you know just buy some more this is what
I I don't know it's probably boring but
it's not it's not too shabby at all
alright so there we go
let's go ahead and dig here I think this
is where we get the first two pieces so
there we go we got the clue hunter
gloves and boots I was right about the
name though pretty proud of myself for
that one alright here we go
piece number two yeah there we go we got
the legs we're getting there we're very
close and here is another piece boom got
the cloak I think all's we needs a body
right I don't think anyone's found the
helmet yet I don't think that's the
thing alright and this should be the
last one that I have to do so there we
go
got the clue hunter garb I don't think
anyone's found the helmet yet as of
right now it's probably been like three
or four months since that thing came out
right at least that's insane but uh
gonna go get some other gear and we're
gonna go do some winter time alright so
there we go I bought all of these for
1.2 mil and like 10k so I was able make
160k off these gonna sell them all back
while I go do some winter tot and I
guess every time that these sell off
I'll come back and do them we have a
bird's nest and at the tree seat lid
alright so wanted to get 41 woodcutting
before I went there so that I could use
a rune
and not look like a club can someone
explain to me what the [__] I just did
it look at this
and it's totally combat bracelet for for
142 K look I literally I just I bought a
6-1 because okay so I sold this one for
27 and I want to see how much I could
buy six one four and I could buy it for
literally med so I'm just going to keep
on charging these and selling these back
as long as some dumbass is paying a
shit-ton for these things I have no
[__] clue what's going on right now
alright so I'm gonna keep trying to sell
these just to see okay damn it bro damn
it
I was man I was hoping I was hoping
alright alright so here we go I just
came into the wrong world but we're
gonna get started on water top now and
see what we can do hopefully we get a
couple pieces of the armor that'd be
pretty nice to get this account started
off but we'll see where how we do there
we go first game done gonna go ahead and
see what I get from this box and first
box done nothing much to speak of Oh 900
points and this one was so close to
getting it to or so close to being able
to get two rolls on the crate but uh
here we go gonna get our loop again and
some dynamite and are lighter seeds
which is worthless
of course the first one that I don't
actually record me getting it I actually
do get a decent reward in 30 burnt pages
I think they're like 3k per one so
that's actually really good yeah 3k per
one so that's a 90k drop right there
I'll take that number eight and more
burnt pages guess we'll take it alright
so as you can see I bought 245 birds
nuts for pretty much 1.08 five mill so
I'm gonna go ahead and see what I can
sell them on for now and there we go
140k profit should be made gonna sell
them all now
alright so overnight was able to sell on
some crushed bird's nests as you can see
well you can't really even see but
that's the problem me not updating it
all the time I made like 450 GP per one
so it wasn't too bad we're up to a total
of 1.8 Mel in the cash stack now we'll
see what we have in the bank it'll kind
of show me in the top so it'll be pretty
quick 350 1k in there so we're over 2
point 1 mil all ready we're just kind of
nice
a little bit more money making methyl
bit more money making today and see
where we can get this bank to a great
number 12 we go ahead and get the warm
gloves that is a little throw those on
get a little more XP now and look for
more pieces of the suit I don't know if
that's what you'd call it but that's
what I called it
alright so we got two different pieces
or two different crates right now so
we'll see if we get anything from these
shoes some burnt pages Oh a lot of burn
pages alright there's another hundred
Kay I'll take that alright Here I am
back again at this time surprisingly not
with birds nests this is corns I
accidentally I meant to I was going to
make them in Don finish potions I
thought you didn't need a level to do
that since you weren't getting any XP
but apparently you do and so I pretty
much just flipped them as you can see I
bought them here for 2.15 mill was able
to sell them all on for 2.2 so I mean
like sub dadk which isn't too bad but
definitely could have made more hide the
herb lower level yep so decided while I
had some bird's nest by I'd go ahead and
kind of level up the account a little
bit so right now we have 44 strengths
working on that right now I'm probably
just gonna go attack and strength until
I get to 60 not all right now but in the
near future so this is pretty chill I've
never killed sand crabs before me and
that gave two perdus fighting for his
pod so he's got a piss but someone else
left so I took this spot but it's really
chill and definitely really afk alright
so here's me getting fifty strengths
there we go so we finally got that done
taking a little bit I'm probably gonna
go ahead and get or at least try to get
50 attack and then I'm gonna go ahead
and go to the GE and start working on
some money-making for this video so that
this should be the end of the training
once I get 50 attack and then we'll get
into some real [__] me never been to
sand crabs before that's what these
things are called right yes Ann Krebs
did not know that they didn't even hurt
you at all pretty much your 40 defense I
didn't even get hit I think I ate maybe
two or three lobsters and they weren't
even necessary but yeah not too bad we
ended up getting the 48 attack and 50
strengths I ran out of potions and my I
think birds nests are done buying I
think that's what I'm working on right
now so I'm gonna go up to the GE and go
and flip those real quick alright so I
was correct and we have 500 bird's nest
spots so I'm going to go ahead and crush
those
there are the 500 nests going to go
ahead and see what we are able to buy
one question asked for to see how much
profit we are actually able to make off
of these so as you can see 45 7 1
I don't know buying these all for about
43 so I made about 270 K or 270 GP on
each one which means I made about 135 K
which isn't too bad I'll take that and
within a couple minutes all 500 birds
nests sold at once I'll take that up to
2.3 milk ashtec well we'll figure out
something else I don't want to keep
doing them but they are there they're
good what can I say alright and here we
go this should be 50 attack could use a
G mom now but as you can see don't have
one thumbs money for it but one thing I
will be doing is whenever I get easy
clues from these I think I'll be doing
them just because I kind of want to get
those like high-tier clue scroll stuff
like I have to completing for 100 or so
I think like those things seem pretty
cool so I'm gonna try and aim for that
on this account so whenever I get an
easy clue we will do it and kind of vary
up the content a little bit damn I
missed it meant to get it on video but
there we go there is 60 strength pretty
excited about that and yeah we hit 67
combat as well times start working on
attack get ourself 60 text then we'll
get a D skim but as I am out of stuff I
am gonna teleport here soon I didn't get
as many easy clues I thought I would I
don't know I don't know I mean I have K
pretty happy on this account but I
didn't notice any last time whenever I
went from forty to fifty attack I
noticed like three or four and within
literally a minute of me saying that
there we go I don't imagine much to the
unimprovable of my viewers the margins
uncrushed and birds nests are back there
we go it says 600 GP margins right now
you know I'm gonna exploit that and I
know it's terrible for content but come
on who wouldn't want that
to step clues that's definitely
something I can get used to but here we
go and first one a whole bottle whole
lot enough but we'll take the logins and
a boom there is the first medium clue we
got that we also got 51 attack while we
were trying to get these so that's
pretty cool I'm gonna go ahead and do
this long as I have all the requirements
I don't think there's that many though
and here we go with in medium casket
three-step flu not too bad let's go
ahead and open it until we get so
some elf camp teleports those are
probably like yeah I mean that's 30k
we'll take it I guess so in total 32 KQ
of nothing too great but not too shabby
alright just got a medium clue this one
actually took me a lot longer I'm a 52
attack almost 53 or like halfway but
what I just realized is deference or 304
GPS so once I'm done with this we are
going to go buy some death threats from
the same age and make a [__] ton of
money so let's [__] do that here in a
second well this clue got me so I have
to give it a cannabis and the Slayer
tower to dig for this clue which I
cannot do but I'm gonna go ahead and do
the quest for it after hopefully these
crushed nuts so they dropped a ton while
I was trying to sell them but I'm just
gonna leave for a little bit and
hopefully they'll sell the meantime
alright and here we go this should be me
finishing the rune mysteries quests
please hey there it is so this is going
to let me do the same Rock mage mini
quests that I need to do to be able by
death rune so that's why I did this is
kind of embarrassing that it took me
this long to do it but there we go
there's my phone and there we go
the same rock mage mini quest done at 9
runecrafting which is cool and I'll be
able to trade him now which is really
the only reason I did this alright so
just got done doing a little bit of
death row and buying 750 death runes I
don't know how much money and started
off with but I know that's good compared
to where we were they're selling right
now for 307 each so we're gonna make a
ton of money off this I can guarantee
you that alright so now I've turned the
750 death runes after two inventories
into 1 point 4 K I'm gonna do what I can
now to sell off these crushed nests
because these death route
death runes are insanely profitable
right now I know I'm gonna make barely
any money on these that's fine with me
right now death runes are up to 320
which is just ridiculous and I'm looking
to exploit that for a ton of money for
this series so let's get into that
alright so there we go now I have 2
point 6 mil I sold off the birds mass
pot a little bit of armor since I'm
risking a little more figure you know
I'll spice it up with a rune armor gonna
see what we can get out there now and
how many dead friends we can buy and how
much we can make so I'm gonna kind of
time how long this takes me and how much
I will make in the end alright so I'm
gonna go ahead and put this on pause for
a moment as you can see I started with I
think I said I think it was 2 6 2 4 K
was how much I started with and as you
can see now we have
that two-point or pretty much three mils
so I've made 360 K in the matter of
eleven minutes which is insane that's
almost two million hours so I'm gonna
keep doing this
but I'm gonna go watch Michigan game so
I'll be back on to it in a second all
right so here we go going to buy off the
rest of the death runes that we can buy
and boom there are all of them that I
can possibly buy with my cash tag so as
you can see we have eleven thousand and
almost two hundred death runes so I'm
gonna go ahead and see what a death rune
is worth and then tell you guys how much
again all right so I found that you
could sell off death runes for 307 GP so
I'm gonna go ahead and do that and as
you can see that brings us to 3.4 mm
plus what we got in the inventory which
is very miniscule but we ended up making
about 600 no we made like 800 K and
doing that that's insane we made 800 K
and barely any time at all so that's
great I'm probably gonna sell those
maybe do one more round maybe and then
probably go do some more rock crabs get
ourself sixty attack and then I'll go
ahead and answer it we're working on
monkey madness
all right so about now I know I'm gonna
hit my login amount that it takes pretty
much to the point to where you can't hop
world's constantly like it'll log you
out for like five minutes you can log
back in but if you log again it'll do
the same thing so you have to take like
a five-minute break I was about to hit
that but this time not as profitable
just purely due to the fact that there
were more people on it's kind of weird
since it's midnight here I figured there
would have been a lot less people
however nothing case there were more
people so I didn't make as much money
because I was constantly buying a lower
stock so I was buying them for a higher
price which is why I won't end up making
as much alright bought a death room for
312 which is actually pretty good I'm
definitely happy about that so gonna go
ahead and sell them as you can see there
that'll be 3.75 mill which will mean
we're up somewhere near like 4.2 ish
which is pretty insane to be honest with
you alright so there we go just got
another easy clue done gonna go ahead
and open that
and all so gonna go ahead and do priest
and barrel now and then finish off the
medium clothes and they'll probably be
it for this episode so let's do it and
here we go this is priests in peril done
so that's good we got that out of the
way and I should be able to go and pass
through this and get a head go along
with my flu I gotta talk to him
nevermind alright so I believe that this
is the last possible step so there we go
a medium casket let's go ahead and see
what we get
so nothing at all surprise
alright so to kind of end off each video
what I think I'm going to do is just go
ahead and show you guys what's in my
bank and what I got going on so we are
finishing off of this video with as you
can see up here 4.5 million I won't have
OS buddy bro because it kind of canceled
that so that's gonna hurt but yeah we
have four point five million cash and
then another male hanging around in the
form of obsidian cabe random stamina
potions and just a bunch of beer and
stuff so that'll be it for this episode
I think we made a lot of progress I had
fun doing this episode and I hope you
guys enjoyed it too if you guys want to
see more of this make sure to leave a
like and comment if you guys want to be
informed as soon as the next video goes
live make sure to subscribe also turn on
notifications if you actually want to
know exactly when it goes live if you
guys wanna know more about me go ahead
and head up the Twitter it's in the
description down below you guys can also
join my clan chat of seven helpers
in-game if you guys want to come by and
say something to me also usually my
private time but it is what it is so
hope you guys have a wonderful day and